what up space fame goes in here from
anime upper back at it again to discuss
the latest and craziest developments in
the one piece story and this is a huge
one right before a very long break four
weeks to be specific so stay tuned for
this upcoming insanity that is this full
translated chapter and a lot of things
that we were confused about in the
spoilers were thankfully addressed in
the full translator pages so we got a
lot of that to go over if you do enjoy
these one-piece reviews and want to keep
them coming you know what to do channel
parking with it and smash that like
button remember smashing his pirating
energy and passing his other energy so
choose wisely and set off those youtube
fireworks to celebrate juano's
liberation if you haven't joined the
nakamura by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates and now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all we got one piece on the
cover of weekly shonen jump as they
advertise the new movie showing shanks's
daughter and everything then we finally
see the color two page spread that we
knew was coming advertising the new
one-piece odyssey game it definitely
looks fun and i may have to just try
this one so this chapter is called the
new emperor's as we know and it starts
with the five elders freaking out over
what is the meaning of this photo
meaning luffy's photo we never approved
of it they say and they thought they
told the marines to remove the d from
the name this was one of my questions
after reading the spoilers as we'll see
the bounty for luffy is not as high as
we had every right to expect and so at
first i thought this was because they
were trying to downplay luffy but then
the spoiler said that luffy's new form
was used and i thought if they want to
downplay luffy the warrior of liberation
who can give hope to the downtrodden
that it didn't make sense that they'd
reveal his awakened form to everyone and
now it all makes sense the five elders
didn't want to reveal luffy's new form
or the d in his name they want to keep
it as hush-hush as possible so of course
they'd be against this photo very
satisfied now because this discrepancy
was bothering me when we lacked all the
information the marine says no sir we
weren't told about that the photo was
sent by cp zeros guernica sama who of
course didn't have all the knowledge
that the elders had the elder says
reprint it the world cannot be permitted
to see this the marine says they've been
trying to contact the printer but
there's no use the elder wants them to
cease distribution but then we see big
news morgan's the goat i love this dude
so much and you know he doesn't care
about what the elders want he says it's
up to us to spread this around the globe
cipher pulls transmission from wano
broke off right after they spotted big
mom's ship the gears of the world he
says won't stop turning he won't let the
elders propaganda slide when the real
story is this thrilling this dude is
legit a hero absolutely love it this is
what news outlets should strive to be we
see people reading the news which speaks
of the defeat of the emperor's big mom
and kaido by the three supernova
captains they were all issued an
extraordinary bounty by the government
we're told although not that
extraordinary in my opinion for luffy 3
billion apiece now for kin and law fans
this is hype since they are being put on
equal footing with luffy all the info of
how luffy soloed kaido is not out and
yes he soloed him for all intents and
purposes it makes sense that maybe they
don't know the full story so they just
looked at it as three supernova taking
down to yonko and that's that or perhaps
more likely when we hear what the elders
were on about the marines are
downplaying luffy but either way they
mistakenly added his new form again i am
disappointed that luffy's bounty is not
over kaido's because he definitely
deserves it to be but now it does make
sense why it's not higher given the
context of the full translator pages
shout out to manfred ng who on my
luffy's new bounty video wrote i'm
looking at 3 billion when i asked
everyone to guess what luffy's new
bounty would be i do personally wish it
was higher but i gotta give props to the
good guests again as i mentioned in my
spoiler video i like how the total of
their bounties is 9 billion their
collective bounties are a bit higher
than kaido and big mom's collective
bounties to symbolize how they together
surpassed them but it's definitely
misleading since i'll just say it luffy
did more and deserves a higher bounty
than law and kit we then see the wano
party and luffy has shown partying and
eating to his heart's content with
chopper and yamato it's a great panel
and much deserved after the epic but
difficult arc luffy just had to endure
brooke is rocking out with hiri a very
nice touch i love that combo meanwhile a
bunch of you guys asked where robin was
in the comments of the last few videos
and we finally see her she's underground
and we find out through a conversation
with tengu a bunch of crazy jaw-dropping
things we find out that tengu was
imprisoned here for a number of years he
did swordsmithing as a hobby because he
had a talent for it but in actuality he
was the former shogun kozuki tsukiaki
aka odin's father we see him take off
the mask for the epic reveal and
everything my brother animak when the
spoilers dropped was wondering why he
didn't try and help odin if he was alive
he was wondering how they'd explain this
and again it's answered here even when
the spoilers are confusing we should
trust oda to explain it well when the
full chapter drops the reason he didn't
help odin was because he was locked away
in this underground room in particular
by the time he got out of the prison
odin was already dead and wano changed
he contemplated seppuku but didn't go
through with it his exact explanation is
interrupted by robin robin interrupts to
talk about another huge thing the
ancient weapon pluton she says this
legendary warship called the world's
worst warship capable of destroying
whole islands in a single shot should be
here in wano and odin's dad confirms
she's right that is huge and that's
something we have to look forward to
when the manga comes back seeing pluton
but for now we move on to the former
prisoner mine in udon roots are coming
from the ground and impaling the former
beast pirates and draining them visibly
it's even happening to king and queen
again we don't know what shape they were
in before this happened but it's still
pretty crazy that green bull the admiral
can take them all down together so
easily the dude is not breaking a sweat
and these are two yonko commanders it
appears he doesn't need to eat since he
can just absorb nutrients like this from
others green bull says himself that he's
at a rank where he'd lose face if he let
a few commanders like king and queen get
the best of him big talk and a reminder
as to just how much of a threat the
admirals are greenville says the navy
doesn't have manpower to waste on the
mess they've left and even insults them
saying not that i expected much of you
bozos this guy is being so patronizing
to serious antagonists of this last arc
that it's really hyping up the marines
as a force to be reckoned with not that
that wasn't clear before but oda is
really emphasizing it here he's also
drinking alcohol from barrels another
potential nod to the green bowl is
zoro's relative theory we do see his
face here though and he's definitely not
a dead ranger for zorro in appearance he
is however from wano clearly since he's
introduced as ryokugyu aramaki and
aramaki is a japanese wano name he lets
whoever is on the phone know that he's
in wano and he says bring a warship he
even says don't tell sakazuki aka kainu
so it suggests that he's hiding
something but we don't know what just
yet then he says he's always dug his
style no half measures he's itching to
get his approval and then seeing luffy's
poster he says he's sure to get an atta
boy if he brings him the brat's head so
i'm guessing he might be talking about
akainu here and wants to surprise and
impress him with luffy but i'm not
completely sure he's talking about
akainu and not someone else let me know
your thoughts in the comments i will say
though based on looks and based on
outwardly saying he wants someone's
approval and an atta boy he doesn't seem
very zoro-esque let me know upon seeing
this do you still think greenville's
related to zorro or does the theory die
for you here for now we return to the
party we get a flashback of what looks
like luffy saying to momo to not tell
anybody about him since he doesn't want
to be a hero so epic i love this dude
doesn't need any of the glory he's just
doing the right thing and as we saw way
back in the beginning of the story he's
totally okay with normal people viewing
him as a pirate to be hated i love that
he doesn't expect gratitude from other
people he just does what he thinks is
the right thing to do kid shows up and
attacks luffy and luffy unintentionally
counters without even meaning to by
pulling him close like he wants kid to
party with him again luffy is clearly
giving off the pirate king laid back
energy here while kidd is so reactionary
the party scenes are amazing and we even
see signs reminiscent of the ones inel
has except for him it's three comma-like
designs rather than just two this is
proclaimed to be the biggest and wildest
festival finally kid tells luffy came to
kill luffy because wait for it they've
announced the four emperors and luffy is
one of them and kid has not this
confused me at first because why would
luffy have the same bounty as law and
kid while the other two didn't even make
yonko while the great buggy d clown did
but i'm guessing this part is the work
of morgan's who knows more even if the
government doesn't want to give luffy
the glory through an extra large bounty
so yeah the new yonko are here shanks
blackbeard luffy and shanks's old fellow
pirate apprentice on the pirate king's
crew buggy the clown this of course
raises questions immediately about what
buggy did to earn this title but for now
let's just appreciate the fact that our
boy buggy made it all this way this dude
said he'd be the pirate god if luffy
were to become the pirate king and you
gotta admit he appears to be backing his
big talk up i'm definitely not gonna
criticize buggy becoming an emperor
until we know more about it for now i'll
just relish the news the chapter ends
with greenville approaching the
celebration and saying the marines
aren't in such a good mood especially
since the rest of the world is a real
mess now we're told times are changing
and also we're told about the four week
breakout is taking very hyped stuff so
many cliffhangers to leave us wanting
more i feel like oda did it because he
knew four weeks would be a lot of time
off and he definitely gave us a chapter
packed to the brim as a result let me
know your thoughts on this chapter
luffy's bounty and our surprise yonko
the great buggy drop a hashtag all hail
buggy in the comment section if you're a
real one and watch to this point if you
enjoy these one piece reviews and want
to keep them coming you know what to do
chiller parking with an end smash that
like button with no mercy remember
smashing his power king energy and
passing his orochi energy so choose
wisely and set off those youtube
fireworks to celebrate juano's
liberation if you haven't joined the
nakama by subscribing and hitting that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications or you will miss future
one-piece videos and updates while you
wait for the excruciating four weeks to
pass until the next chapter feel free to
check out my growing and big one piece
playlist that includes videos on all the
yonko warlords admiral supernova and
much more link to that is in the
description and until next time see ya
space cowboys